For over 20 years, Eric Capstick's worked for Yankee Stadium. He's a camera operator. During the game, he runs around the crowd, looking for fans to put up on this impossibly huge TV screen that sits over the outfield. And I've seen lots of people work a crowd with a microphone or a camera over the years, and I can say definitively, he is masterful.
Eric Capstick 在洋基体育场工作了 20 多年，他是一名摄像师。比赛期间，他奔波在人群中，寻找观众，把他们展示在外场上方那个巨大的电视屏幕上。多年来，我见过很多人拿着麦克风或摄像机活跃气氛，我可以肯定地说，他是大师级的。
So I'd appreciate it if you gave me some really great energy, like [GROWLS] you know, positive Yankee energy. Are you guys a bachelorette party or something?
所以我希望你们能展现出非常棒的活力，比如 [低吼] 你们懂的，积极的洋基精神。你们是单身派对之类的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right. I'm going to try and get you for the second shot.
好吧，我要试着在第二个镜头里拍你们。
Yay.
耶。
He's this lanky, friendly guy. By the way, he seems to know everybody working in the stadium.
他是一个瘦长、友好的家伙。顺便说一句，他似乎认识体育场里工作的每一个人。
Daphne and Curtis.
Daphne 和 Curtis。
What's good?
怎么了？
What's up, bro?
兄弟，怎么了？
When he walks past, he tosses them pieces of bubblegum that he swiped from the Yankees dugout.
当他经过时，他会扔给他们从洋基队休息区顺来的泡泡糖。
Danny.
Danny。
A piece of gum arcs through the air.
一块口香糖在空中划过弧线。
Oh, he dropped it. He dropped it. But usually, he has pretty good hands. I like to say that half the people in the building can't catch. It's pretty accurate, actually.
哦，他没接住。他没接住。但通常他的手感很好。我喜欢说楼里有一半人接不住东西。实际上，这很准确。
The whole purpose of putting fans up on the big screen is to keep the crowd energized between innings, when nothing's happening on the field. So what Eric's looking for is pumped up, passionate fans.
把观众放在大屏幕上的全部目的就是在局间休息、球场上没有比赛时保持观众的活力。所以 Eric 寻找的是充满激情、热情高涨的观众。
Sometimes fans ask for Kiss Cam. I'm like, no, you got to go to Queens for Kiss Cam. We don't do Kiss Cam here.
有时粉丝会要求 Kiss Cam（接吻镜头）。我心想，不，想看 Kiss Cam 得去皇后区。我们这里不做 Kiss Cam。
You get that Queens reference? He's saying Kiss Cam's the kind of low-brow garbage that you see at Mets games.
你明白那个关于皇后区的梗吗？他是说 Kiss Cam 那种低俗的玩意儿你在大都会队的比赛里才看得到。
How are you doing? Hi, I want to get the kids. I mean, you know, primarily, so you should sit, probably.
你们好吗？嗨，我想拍这些孩子。我是说，你知道，主要得拍他们，所以你们最好还是坐下。
He's talking to some teachers and parents of kids from a school, PS 71 in the Bronx. They're here on a class trip.
他正在和来自布朗克斯 71 小学的一些老师和孩子家长交谈。他们是来参加班级旅行的。
You don't want to be in it?
你不想出镜吗？
Eric likes to position himself between the people who he's shooting and the screen, so they can actually see themselves on the huge screen right over his shoulder. Sometimes that means perching himself over the edge of a balcony, but not this time.
Eric 喜欢把自己定位在他拍摄的人和屏幕之间，这样他们就能在他肩膀上方的巨大屏幕上看到自己。有时这意味着他得骑在阳台边缘，但这次不用。
We're about 10 seconds away.
我们还有 10 秒钟。
Everybody waits. It feels like a long time.
每个人都在等待。感觉时间过了很久。
Here we go. You're up. Hey, you're [INAUDIBLE].
我们开始吧。轮到你们了。嘿，你们是 [听不清]。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Cool!
酷！
Have you been on TV before?
你以前上过电视吗？
No.
没有。
So how was it?
感觉怎么样？
I don't know. Exciting, yeah.
不知道。很刺激，是的。
And so what's so fun about being on TV?
上电视有什么好玩的？
Like, you just get to see yourself on there, and it makes you feel famous.
就像，你可以在那上面看到自己，让你感觉自己很有名。
How did you know what to do when the camera went on you?
当摄像机对准你时，你怎么知道该做什么？
Well, I've seen people and what they do. Like, they wave and stuff.
嗯，我见过别人怎么做。比如，他们挥手之类的。
Duh-- even if you're in fourth grade. The camera's a magic wand. Somebody points it at you, you know what to do. A few friends sitting near these kids-- Kristen, and Joanne, and Howie-- they saw Eric, and they called out to him that he should shoot them next because it was Joanne's birthday. Eric saw right through that. I didn't.
废话——即使你是四年级学生也一样。摄像机就像一根魔杖。有人把它指向你，你就知道该做什么。这几个坐在孩子附近的朋友——Kristen、Joanne 和 Howie——他们看到了 Eric，并对他大喊，让他下一个拍他们，因为今天是 Joanne 的生日。Eric 一眼就看穿了，但我没看出来。
It's your birthday?
今天是你的生日？
No, it's not my birthday. He lied because I wanted to be on the camera.
不，不是我的生日。他撒谎是因为我想上镜。
Why do you want to be on the camera?
你为什么要上镜？
I don't know. Because I love the Yankees, and I'm happy to be here. And I want all my friends to be on TV.
不知道。因为我爱洋基队，我很高兴能来到这里。而且我希望我所有的朋友都能上电视。
Kristen and her friend was actually on the big screen once.
Kristen 和她的朋友确实上过一次大屏幕。
Oh my god, it's so exciting. People saw me on TV, and they texted me from home [INAUDIBLE]. We see you on camera. It was my moment of fame. I've never been on TV before. I was on TV.
天哪，太令人兴奋了。人们在电视上看到了我，他们从家里给我发短信 [听不清]。我们在镜头里看到你了。这是我成名的时刻。我以前从没上过电视。我上电视了。
Well, we actually were on TV once last-- two seasons ago. There was a ball that came out, and our friend--
其实我们上过一次电视，是在……两个赛季前。当时有一个球飞出来，我们的朋友……
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
[INAUDIBLE] first home run, and our friend caught the ball and dropped it.
[听不清] 第一个本垒打，我们的朋友接住了球，但又掉了。
And it fell right on our seats, and we all bent over to get it. And then we watched SportsCenter that night, and you saw all of us like, ahh, and bent over. And that's our one time we were on TV.
它直接掉在我们的座位上，我们都弯下腰去捡。那天晚上我们看了 SportsCenter 节目，你看到我们所有人都在那里“啊”，弯着腰。那是我们唯一一次上电视。
So they were on SportsCenter-- SportsCenter. It's so far away in the stands, so small on the screen, that nobody they knew recognized them. Nobody texted, nobody called. Yet still, it's kind of satisfying.
所以他们上了 SportsCenter——SportsCenter。他们在看台上离得太远，在屏幕上太小，以至于他们认识的人都没认出他们。没人发短信，没人打电话。然而，这仍然让人感到满足。
Like I DVRed SportsCenter and then paused it and took pictures of the TV. And every year it shows up in my Facebook memories, I share it. I'm like, oh, that's when Wayne blew the ball. [LAUGHS]
我把 SportsCenter 录了下来，暂停并拍了电视的照片。每年它都会出现在我的 Facebook 回忆里，我就会分享它。我说，噢，那就是 Wayne 漏掉那个球的时候。[笑声]
You're only on the big screen at the stadium for a few seconds. But to get there, one woman told me, it makes your day. Another said she was recognized on the subway on the way home from a game that she had been on the screen. It's like this thrilling thing the Yankees can bestow on any lucky fan. So much better than a bobblehead. Because who doesn't want to get on TV?
你在体育场的大屏幕上只出现几秒钟。但正如一位女士告诉我的，这能让你这一天过得很开心。另一位说她在回家的地铁上被认出来了，因为她出现在屏幕上。这就像洋基队可以赐予任何幸运粉丝的一件令人兴奋的事情。比摇头娃娃好多了。因为谁不想上电视呢？
Well, today on our program, non-TV people suddenly find themselves on TV. They didn't expect it. They didn't ask for it. They just found out they were, whether they wanted it or didn't want it. And some definitely did not want it. Others didn't even know it was happening because they're babies. What that kind of attention can do to you. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，非电视界人士突然发现自己上了电视。他们没预料到，也没要求。他们只是发现自己上镜了，不管他们想不想。有些人绝对不想上。有些人甚至不知道发生了什么，因为他们还是婴儿。这种关注会对你产生什么影响。来自 WBEZ 芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act I. Anything You Say Can and Will Be Used on Television. So since the 1980s, there's been a way that tons of ordinary Americans suddenly found themselves on TV, though it probably was not how they wanted to be making their TV debuts.
第一幕。你说的任何话都可能并在将来会被用于电视。自 20 世纪 80 年代以来，数以百万计的普通美国人突然发现自己上了电视，尽管这可能不是他们想要的电视首秀方式。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
Stop. Stop. Stop. OK.
停。停。停。好吧。
So if you live in this country, you probably know the TV show Cops. This particular clip is from a kind of updated version of Cops called Live PD, which is made by a different company. It's actually more popular than Cops these days. And with me to discuss this is Dan Taberski. And Dan, you have watched a lot of these shows over the years.
如果你住在这个国家，你可能知道电视节目《Cops》（警察）。这个片段来自《Cops》的一个升级版，叫《Live PD》，是由另一家公司制作的。如今它实际上比《Cops》更受欢迎。和我一起讨论这件事的是 Dan Taberski。Dan，多年来你看了很多这样的节目。
I have. I have watched a lot of Cops. I've watched a lot of Cops over the years-- too much.
是的。这些年来我看了很多《Cops》。我看过很多——太多了。
And I know that one of the things that's interested you about that show and that you enjoy when you watch a show, it comes from the fact that you yourself used to make television.
我知道你对那个节目的兴趣，以及你在观看节目时的享受，源于你自己也曾经制作过电视节目。
Yeah, I did for a long time. And a lot of reality shows, too, mostly kid shows and game shows, silly stuff. But I know what tricks that you employ in making a reality show. And I've always wondered, how were they doing this? What are the tricks that they're using? What's the difference between what they're showing me on TV versus reality?
是的，我做了很久。还有很多真人秀，大多是儿童节目和游戏节目，些愚蠢的东西。但我知道制作真人秀时所用的技巧。我一直很好奇，他们是怎么做到的？他们用了什么招数？他们在电视上展示的内容与现实有什么区别？
Like, what really happened?
比如，到底发生了什么？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，没错。
And you have a new podcast about this very question. It's called Running from Cops. I've listened to the whole thing. It's a great show. And in this show, you take that question apart for Cops and for Live PD. And I think before we get further, you should explain what Live PD is for the people who haven't seen it.
你有一个关于这个问题的播客。叫《Running from Cops》（逃离警察）。我听完了整部节目。这是一个很棒的节目。在这个节目中，你拆解了《Cops》和《Live PD》的这个问题。我想在我们深入探讨之前，你应该为那些没看过的人解释一下什么是《Live PD》。
Yeah, the thing about Live PD is that half the country doesn't even know what it is. And in the meantime, it was the most DVRed show of 2018. It's three hours long of live policing on Friday night and then another three hours of live policing on Saturday night.
是的，《Live PD》的情况是，半个国家甚至不知道它是什么。但同时，它是 2018 年被录制次数最多的节目。它有 3 个小时的周五晚直播警务，还有 3 个小时的周六晚直播警务。
So it is a lot of hours of television. And just so people can picture the show, describe what Live PD looks like, what makes it different from Cops.
所以这是一个非常长的电视节目。为了让人们想象一下这个节目，描述一下《Live PD》看起来是什么样子的，它与《Cops》有什么不同。
Live PD is mainly different because it's live. It's basically set up like any SBN show. So there's a host, and there's all these monitors behind him. And the monitors are following six to eight police departments around the country live. And he just keeps cutting to different police departments to show you the highlights of what's going on right now.
《Live PD》主要是因为它是在直播。它基本像任何体育直播节目一样设置。有一个主持人，他身后有很多监视器。监视器直播跟随全国六到八个警察局。他不断切换到不同的警察局，向你展示正在发生的事情的亮点。
Let's go right now to Jeffersonville. Both of the officers, Alyssa Wright and Denver Leverett, are serving as backup on a speeding pullover. Let's see why.
我们现在前往杰斐逊维尔。两位警官 Alyssa Wright 和 Denver Leverett 正在为一次超速拦截提供支援。让我们看看原因。
Both hands out the window.
双手伸出窗外。
And then they go back to the studio, where there's a couple of police officers offering analysis and color commentary about what they're seeing.
然后他们回到演播室，那里有几位警官对他们所看到的进行分析和评论。
If they're aggressive, you're going to try to use less lethal to taser, pepper spray, to try to control the situation. Now you're dealing with a dog and the suspect at the same time. It makes it a lot more difficult.
如果他们有攻击性，你会尝试使用较少致命的泰瑟枪、胡椒喷雾来控制局面。现在你同时在处理一只警犬和嫌疑人。这会让事情变得更困难。
Yeah.
是的。
So one thing that's interesting about Live PD is that it premiered in 2016, right? Right when there was this proliferation of people filming their own police interactions on their own phones and putting it on YouTube. And it really changed the conversation around policing.
关于《Live PD》有一点很有趣，它是 2016 年首播的，对吧？正是人们大量用手机拍摄自己与警察的互动并放到 YouTube 上的时期。它确实改变了关于警务的讨论。
Lots of videos of people getting shot by the police.
很多警察枪击人们的视频。
Yeah, and Live PD consciously positions itself and markets itself as a response to all that.
是的，《Live PD》自觉地将自己定位并推销为对所有这些的回应。
To the videos.
对那些视频的回应。
Right. Like, we're going to go a step further than your iPhone video or your body cam. We will bring it to you live. It doesn't get more real than this. That's their position. So here's a promotional video they put up.
没错。就像，我们要比你的 iPhone 视频或执法记录仪更进一步。我们将为您带来现场直播。没有比这更真实的了。这就是他们的立场。这是他们发布的宣传视频。
Being able to see exactly what the police are doing and how they're doing it is beneficial to everyone.
能够清楚地看到警察在做什么以及他们是如何做的，这对每个人都有好处。
The cell phone changed everything. Being able to instantly load video up.
手机改变了一切。能够即时上传视频。
You have to be very carefully in these situations.
在这种情况下你必须非常小心。
They only put up what they want to put up. They don't get the whole interaction.
他们只上传他们想上传的东西。他们没有拍到整个互动过程。
So for police departments wanting to get their side out in this atmosphere, Live PD is great on TV and also social media. Unlike Cops, which is sort of old school, Live PD has a big social media presence. It's a live show. People tweet along live. They have a rabid fan base. During the show, the police departments will actually tweet, if you liked seeing Pasco County, Florida, for example, on Live PD, here's how you can apply to become an officer yourself. So I spoke to this one guy, Sheriff Ozzie Knezovich. He's the sheriff in Spokane, Washington. And that's one of the places where Live PD's been filming.
所以对于想要在这种氛围中传达自己立场的警察局来说，《Live PD》在电视和社交媒体上都很棒。不像《Cops》那种老派做法，《Live PD》拥有巨大的社交媒体存在感。这是一个直播节目。人们实时发推文互动。他们拥有狂热的粉丝群。节目期间，警察局甚至会发推文，如果你喜欢在《Live PD》上看到佛罗里达州帕斯科县，这里有你可以申请成为警官的方式。所以我采访了这位警长 Ozzie Knezovich。他是华盛顿州斯波坎市的警长。那是《Live PD》拍摄的地点之一。
This thing has tapped into something that I can't explain. I've never seen anything like it before-- not in 28 years. I can tell you that Live PD has done wonders for our recruiting.
这东西触及了一些我无法解释的东西。我从未见过这样的事情——在我这 28 年里。我可以告诉你，《Live PD》对我们的招募工作创造了奇迹。
Really? How?
真的吗？怎么做到的？
Applications-- people calling us all over the country.
申请——人们从全国各地打电话给我们。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. It's been amazing. It's been amazing the amount of Christmas cards we got from people all over the country.
是的。这太惊人了。我们从全国各地收到那么多的圣诞卡，真是令人惊奇。
Get out of here.
别开玩笑了。
No. It shows people at their worst. Well, no, it shows what we're dealing with. It shows what society is dealing with.
不。它展示了人们最糟糕的一面。好吧，不，它展示了我们正在处理的事情。它展示了社会正在处理的事情。
So one of the things that's the most interesting about your series, Running from Cops, is that you really do try to figure out what is the gap between what the programs show us and what really happened out on the street. And as part of that, you and your team watched how many hours?
你系列节目《Running from Cops》最有趣的地方之一，就是你真的试图找出节目展示给我们的内容与街头实际发生的事情之间的差距。作为其中的一部分，你和你的团队看了多少个小时？
846 episodes of Cops.
846 集《Cops》。
Wow.
哇。
And for Live PD, we watched hundreds of hours.
对于《Live PD》，我们看了数百个小时。
And the 846 episodes of Cops, why 846?
那 846 集《Cops》，为什么是 846？
That's all we can get. [LAUGHS] That is what was available to us. There have been over 1,000, and we could get 846.
那是我们能拿到的全部。[笑声] 这就是我们能获取的资源。已经有超过 1000 集了，我们只能拿到 846 集。
And so now, what we've done is we've asked you to do an excerpt from your series here for us, where you try to figure out the gap between what we see on these two programs and what really happened, and where you talk to the people getting arrested on Live PD and on Cops about the experience of being reluctantly put on television.
所以现在，我们请你在这里为我们做个节选，你试图找出这两个节目中我们看到的与实际发生的事情之间的差距，以及你采访那些在《Live PD》和《Cops》中被逮捕的人，关于被迫上电视的体验。
Right.
没错。
And so what's going to happen now is you're going to start with Cops and then go to Live PD. Take it away.
所以现在会发生的是，你将从《Cops》开始，然后转到《Live PD》。请开始吧。
We'll start here. This is Cops, 2013, season 26, episode 14. This scene happens in Gwinnett County, Georgia. It's after midnight, and an officer pulls up on two teenagers. They're parked in a church parking lot.
我们从这里开始。这是《Cops》，2013 年，第 26 季，第 14 集。这一幕发生在佐治亚州格温内特县。午夜过后，一名警官截停了两个青少年。他们停在一个教堂的停车场里。
Hey, how are you doing?
嘿，你们好吗？
Great, how are you?
很好，你呢？
Good. What are you guys doing here?
很好。你们在这里做什么？
Just hanging out.
只是待着。
Just hanging out? OK, well, it's the church, and it's closed.
只是待着？好吧，这是教堂，而且已经关门了。
Are we not supposed to be here? OK.
我们不应该在这里吗？好吧。
So you guys have your IDs with you?
所以你们带身份证了吗？
I've got mine.
我有我的。
Anything illegal, drugs, anything like that at all?
有非法物品吗，毒品，之类的东西吗？
No.
没有。
No? OK. Would you mind if I check to make sure there's nothing illegal in the car?
没有吗？好吧。你介意我检查一下车里没有非法物品吗？
Yeah.
好吧。
OK.
行。
The guy tells the officer that he's out on bond for possession of cocaine, but that he's been clean for a month. So now we're all getting suspicious, right?
那个人告诉警官他因为持有可卡因正在保释期，但他已经一个月没碰了。所以现在我们都起疑心了，对吧？
Just leave it there for now.
暂时放在那儿就行。
The cop starts rooting around in the front seat, past the half-drunk soda cups and empty chip bags on the floorboard. And pretty much immediately, he finds what he is looking for.
警察开始在副驾驶座翻找，越过地板上喝了一半的苏打水杯和空薯片袋。他几乎立刻找到了他要找的东西。
This right here, crack cocaine has almost like a cake consistency to it. So we're going to nick test a portion of that and see-- test a small amount.
这个，可卡因的质地几乎像蛋糕一样。所以我们要取一部分做一个快速测试，看看——测试一小部分。
The officer picks up a sample, and he does what's called a nick test, a roadside drug test.
警官取了一个样本，做了所谓的“尼克测试”，即路边毒品测试。
If it ends up being cocaine, it'll have a blue or a blue over pink change to it. And that would be cocaine. The blue hue on the pink on the bottom, that's positive for cocaine.
如果最终是可卡因，它会变成蓝色，或者蓝色变粉色。那就是可卡因。底部粉色上的蓝色色调，说明可卡因检测呈阳性。
The guy and the girl look stunned. They deny the cocaine is theirs. The cop arrests them both.
那个男人和女孩看起来惊呆了。他们否认可卡因是他们的。警察逮捕了他们俩。
You're being placed under arrest for possession of cocaine. Just go ahead and place your hands behind your back, OK?
你因持有可卡因被捕。继续，把你的手放在背后，好吗？
And scene. It goes to commercial.
场面结束。进入广告。
Now I know my way around a reality show edit room. And as far as reality shows go, Cops seems pretty real. In that segment we just watched, there's no music. There's no narrator. It's just edited-down observational filming of police at work. That's what I like about it. And it's that style that makes it so believable to the casual viewer. It is what it is-- until it's not.
现在我知道真人秀剪辑室是怎么回事了。就真人秀而言，《Cops》看起来非常真实。在我们刚才看的那个片段中，没有音乐。没有旁白。它只是经过剪辑的警察工作纪实拍摄。这就是我喜欢它的原因。正是这种风格让它在普通观众眼中如此可信。这就是事实——直到它不再是为止。
Did you always want to be a police officer? Was that always the plan?
你一直想当警察吗？一直都有这个计划吗？
I don't know. It seemed like a good idea at the time.
不知道。当时觉得这是个好主意。
Really? It would never seem like a good idea to me. It seems dangerous, and difficult-- and thankless, often.
真的吗？对我来说这永远不会是个好主意。这看起来很危险，很难——而且经常是吃力不讨好的。
It is dangerous, and it is difficult, and it's very thankless.
确实很危险，确实很难，而且非常吃力不讨好。
This is John Burdges. He's a former narcotics officer, and he loved it. But after 14 years on the job, he went to law school. He's been a defense attorney ever since here in Buford, Georgia, where he was retained by that young woman in that Cops episode that we just heard.
这是 John Burdges。他曾是一名缉毒警察，他很喜欢那份工作。但在那份工作干了 14 年后，他去读了法学院。从那以后他一直是佐治亚州布福德的一名辩护律师，他受聘于我们刚才听到的那个《Cops》剧集里的年轻女子。
I thought she was guilty, having been in law enforcement. And I'm very fond of the police, and I'm very pro-police. But I just thought it was a regular episode. So did her family, and so did the district attorney, and so did everybody else.
作为执法人员，我以为她有罪。而且我很喜欢警察，我也非常支持警察。但我只是以为那是一集普通的节目。她的家人也是这么想的，地区检察官也是这么想的，每个人都这么想。
Until, that is, a secondary test on that drug sample taken on the scene came back from the lab.
直到，在现场提取的毒品样本的二次检测从实验室传回来。
The alleged cocaine came back negative from the state lab that it was not cocaine. In fact, it was nothing. They couldn't figure out what it was. But it was certainly not a drug.
所谓的毒品从州实验室传回的结果是阴性，它不是可卡因。实际上，它什么都不是。他们搞不清那是什么。但可以肯定不是毒品。
In fact, that roadside drug test in that episode, they do them all the time on Cops. The colors tell you if it's coke or not. Easy-peasy. But what they never say on Cops, and which I didn't know myself, until now, is that, in fact, those tests, pretty much every jurisdiction in the country says they are inadmissible at trial, including Gwinnett County, Georgia, where that young woman and her boyfriend were arrested. But when that test pops up as blue on Cops, they never say, well, we'll see how the official test comes back. They say--
事实上，那一集中路边的毒品测试，他们在《Cops》里一直这样做。颜色告诉你是不是可卡因。很简单。但《Cops》里从来没说，我自己直到现在才知道，实际上在全国几乎所有的司法管辖区，这些测试在审判中是不可采信的，包括那个年轻女子和她男友被捕的佐治亚州格温内特县。但当测试在《Cops》上显示为蓝色时，他们从不说明，“好吧，让我们看看官方检测结果会怎样”。他们说——
And that would be cocaine.
那会是可卡因。
But it wasn't. And that's not the only discrepancy that John Burdges learned about as this case progressed. The cop didn't just open the car door and find the suspected drugs, like on the show. He searched for 14 minutes before testing anything. And he didn't just do one test, like they show in that episode. He actually tested it two times for coke before it came back blue. One month after the official test results showed it wasn't cocaine, the producers of Cops aired that episode anyway, attracting the wrong kind of notoriety for Burgess' client.
但它不是。那并不是 John Burdges 在案件进展过程中了解到的唯一差异。警察并没有像节目中那样直接打开车门找到疑似毒品。他在测试任何东西之前搜索了 14 分钟。而且他也没有像节目中展示的那样只做了一次测试。实际上他测试了两次可卡因才变成蓝色。在官方检测结果显示它不是可卡因的一个月后，《Cops》的制作人还是播出了那一集，给 Burgess 的当事人带来了错误的名誉损失。
And in fact, she ended up, over a period of a few months, moving out of Gwinnett County, where she grew up, several miles away. You put this young lady through this for what? To film a damn TV show. And nobody cares.
事实上，在接下来的几个月里，她最终搬离了她长大的格温内特县，搬到了几英里外。你为了什么让这位年轻女士经历这些？为了拍个该死的电视节目。而且根本没人关心。
Burgess's client didn't want to talk to me. She's trying to put the whole thing behind her. But why would she have agreed to be on Cops in the first place? Because the thing is for pretty much any reality show, Cops included, the producers do need your consent to show your face on their show, usually by signing a consent form. Why would anyone who just got arrested sign that piece of paper?
Burgess 的当事人不想跟我谈。她正试图把这一切抛在脑后。但她当初为什么要同意上《Cops》呢？因为问题在于对于几乎任何真人秀节目，包括《Cops》，制作人确实需要你的同意才能在节目中展示你的脸，通常是通过签署同意书。为什么刚被捕的人会签那张纸？
Well, you got to talk to people, and you got to persuade them. Any producer that is worth a salt knows that.
好吧，你必须和人们交谈，你必须说服他们。任何有价值的制作人都知道这一点。
John Langley is the co-creator of Cops. 30 years later, he still produces the show, now with the help of his son, Morgan.
John Langley 是《Cops》的联合创始人。30 年后，他仍然在制作这个节目，现在是在他儿子 Morgan 的帮助下。
Most people who sign do so fully cognizant of what they're doing.
大多数签署的人都是充分意识到自己在做什么。
It's just like, they talk to him and listen--
就像，他们和他谈话，听着——
Here's the good news. At this stage of our show's life, people know the show, and it has a certain pop cultural iconic value. And they'll say, get those news cameras away from me. Say, we're with the Cops crew, and they go, oh, Cops. Well, that's OK.
这是个好消息。在我们节目生涯的这个阶段，人们知道这个节目，它具有一定的流行文化标志性价值。他们会说，让那些新闻摄像机离我远点。说，我们是《Cops》剧组，他们会说，哦，《Cops》。嗯，那没关系。
I've actually heard Langley say this before, that people want to be reality show famous, even if it's Cops famous. And I've always found it hard to believe, but you kind of gotta take his word for it, unless you're going to track down the people who have been filmed by Cops and ask them yourself. And so we did.
我确实听过 Langley 这么说过，人们想出名，即使是《Cops》式的出名。我一直觉得难以置信，但除非你去追踪那些被《Cops》拍摄的人并亲自询问，否则你只能听他的。所以我们就这么做了。
Because I was given a choice. Sign if I go to jail. I don't feel like the TV show should have anything to do with my freedom.
因为我被给了个选择。如果不签就得坐牢。我觉得电视节目不应该和我的自由有任何关系。
Corey Robinson was chased and filmed by Cops on his 18th birthday, while he was hanging out in a park in Tampa, Florida. And he says when he was sitting in the back of a police car, the first person to approach him wasn't a cop, but rather a producer from Cops, the show, who told him--
Corey Robinson 在他 18 岁生日那天在佛罗里达州坦帕的一个公园里游荡时被《Cops》追捕并拍摄。他说当他坐在警车后座时，第一个靠近他的人不是警察，而是《Cops》的制作人，他告诉他——
I need you to sign this release form, or you're going to jail with a felony trespassing.
我需要你签这份授权书，否则你就要因为重罪非法入侵被关进监狱。
So Corey says no way. And he asks to talk to an actual cop. And he says to the officer--
所以 Corey 说绝不。他要求和真正的警察谈谈。他对警官说——
They're telling me you're charging me with a felony trespassing, and I'm going to jail if I don't sign a release form. He was like, yeah, you should take him up on his offer. He's trying to help you. You need to sign the paper, or you go to jail. He put the window up, and he walked away.
他们告诉我你正在指控我重罪非法入侵，如果我不签授权书我就要坐牢。他说，是的，你应该接受他的提议。他在试图帮助你。你需要签那张纸，否则你就去坐牢。他关上窗户，走开了。
In fact, of the nine people we were able to find who had been filmed by Cops, all but one say they didn't sign a release, were too drunk or high to do it willingly, or they were coerced into it, like Corey Robinson. And that young woman in that video that I played you, the cocaine bust that turned out to not be cocaine--
事实上，在我们找到的九个被《Cops》拍摄的人中，除了一人之外，所有人都说他们没签授权书，要么喝醉了或磕了药无法自愿去做，要么像 Corey Robinson 一样被强迫去做。还有视频里的那个年轻女子，那个最终证明不是可卡因的可卡因抓捕——
Does that not look like cocaine?
那看起来不像可卡因吗？
What is that?
那是什么？
Cocaine.
可卡因。
According to her attorney, John Burdges--
根据她的律师 John Burdges 的说法——
They told her, you either sign this waiver, or you won't get a bond. So you're sitting in jail in a holding area. You're 18 years old, and you can't get out of jail unless you sign this piece of paper. So yeah, she signed a waiver, but it was not voluntary. Nothing's voluntary when you got handcuffs on.
他们告诉她，要么签这份弃权书，要么就得不到保释。所以你坐在监狱的拘留区里。你 18 岁，除非签了这张纸，否则你出不去。所以是的，她签了弃权书，但这并非出于自愿。当你被戴上手铐时，没有什么是自愿的。
The producers of Cops maintain that they don't coerce subjects to sign consent forms and that they won't even consider a segment for the show unless they have a signed release in hand. A spokesperson told us sometimes people sign, then regret it, and make, quote, "outrageous allegations." So that's Cops. There's more going on than what you see on screen.
《Cops》的制作人坚称他们不会强迫拍摄对象签署同意书，而且除非他们手头有签署的授权书，否则他们甚至不会考虑把拍摄片段放进节目。一位发言人告诉我们，有时人们签了，然后后悔了，就做出所谓的“令人震惊的指控”。所以这就是《Cops》。屏幕上看到的比实际发生的要复杂得多。
But what about Live PD? I mean, it's live. How do you manipulate live? Nothing is more it is what it is than a live TV show, right? No one from Live PD would talk to us about the show or how it's produced. And so we set out to find the answer ourselves by tracking down suspects who have been on the show and having conversations about what actually ended up on television. In the past three years, they've shot in over 30 cities. And so we picked one-- Spokane, Washington.
但是《Live PD》呢？我是说，它是直播。你怎么操控直播？没有比现场直播节目更真实的东西了，对吧？没有《Live PD》的人愿意和我们谈论节目及其制作方式。所以我们通过追踪在该节目中出现过的嫌疑人，并就最终在电视上播出的内容进行对话，试图自己找出答案。在过去三年里，他们在 30 多个城市拍摄。所以我们挑选了一个——华盛顿州斯波坎市。
Welcome back. Let's go to Spokane County, Washington. Deputy van Patton is there. And oh, no, looks like we've got another shirtless dude.
欢迎回来。让我们去华盛顿州斯波坎县。副警长 van Patton 在那里。噢，不，看起来我们又有另一个打赤膊的家伙了。
Spokane's 89% white. And like a lot of places, they've got a pretty serious opioid problem. The city's been on 99 hours of Live PD. And so me and my producers, we watched them all.
斯波坎 89% 是白人。像许多地方一样，他们有相当严重的阿片类药物问题。这个城市在《Live PD》上出现了 99 个小时。我和我的制作人看完了所有的内容。
Meth or heroin, James?
海洛因还是冰毒，James？
Not doing anything.
什么也没做。
All right, James, you have the right to remain silent.
好的，James，你有权保持沉默。
The goal was to look for clues as to the suspect's identity. They only say their first names, if even that. So we look for a first name, or a street sign maybe, so that we could see where the arrest happened. And then we would cross-reference that with court records from around the same time, trying to find a match. And that is how my producer Henry and I met Amy.
目标是寻找嫌疑人身份的线索。他们只说名字，如果连名字都不说的话。所以我们寻找名字，或者可能是路牌，这样我们就能看到逮捕发生在哪里。然后我们会在同一时间左右的法庭记录中进行交叉核对，试图找到匹配项。这就是我的制作人 Henry 和我遇到 Amy 的经过。
What do you think? I'm going to just kind of mic it, like, back and forth.
你觉得呢？我只是想把它麦克风别在那儿，来回调整一下。
This is weird. It's like I'm being interrogated, but not by police officers. And remember it this time.
这很奇怪。感觉就像我在被审问，但不是警察。这次要记住。
Amy was on Live PD, season 2, episode 21. I'll play a little bit of that episode for you.
Amy 在《Live PD》第 2 季第 21 集里。我给你播一小段那一集。
Excuse me. Oh, is she drunk?
打扰一下。噢，她是喝醉了吗？
A Spokane County Sheriff's deputy is responding to a call about a disturbance. And they find a woman in her late 30s. That's Amy.
斯波坎县警长的副手正在回应关于骚乱的报警。他们发现了一个 30 多岁的女人。那就是 Amy。
Then why are you sitting on the floor, crying?
那你为什么坐在地板上哭？
Because I'm drunk. And I lose everything I love.
因为我喝醉了。我失去了我爱的一切。
OK. So you weren't arguing, just drunk and obnoxious is all?
好吧。所以你们没有吵架，只是喝醉了，令人讨厌，仅此而已？
She's sitting on the floor of what looks like a trailer behind a regular house. Amy is drunk. Drunk drunk.
她坐在看起来像普通房子后面的拖车地板上。Amy 喝醉了。烂醉如泥。
Sure. OK. Do you have shoes? Let's walk out. Come on. Let's get you out of this nice gentleman's trailer so he can enjoy his evening.
当然。好吧。你有鞋子吗？我们走吧。来吧。让我们带你离开这位绅士的拖车，让他可以享受他的夜晚。
They don't explain where or why they're even moving her, and they don't wait for shoes. There are six inches of snow on the ground, and they drag her through it in her pink socks.
他们甚至没有解释他们为什么要带走她，也没等她穿鞋。地上有 6 英寸厚的雪，他们拖着她走过雪地，她脚上只穿着粉红色的袜子。
OK. OK.
好吧。好吧。
The officer runs a check on her name, and a warrant comes out.
警官检查了她的名字，发现了一份逮捕令。
You've got a felony warrant for possession of stolen property, OK?
你有一份持有赃物的重罪逮捕令，明白吗？
What possession of stolen property?
什么持有赃物？
I don't know. Come on, let's walk.
不知道。走吧，我们走。
I didn't do nothing. You're arresting me for nothing. I have no [BLEEP].
我什么都没做。你因为莫须有的罪名逮捕我。我没有 [哔]。
The warrant isn't actually for stolen property. It's for failure to appear in court. They cuff her in the snow in her socks. You can see her breath.
逮捕令实际上不是因为持有赃物。而是因为未能出庭。他们在雪地里用袜子戴上了手铐。你可以看到她的呼吸。
Please don't. I've got no shirt on underneath. Please don't.
请不要。我里面没穿衬衫。请不要。
Hey, relax. He's just making sure you don't have anything on you.
嘿，放松。他只是在确保你身上没有携带任何东西。
I have no shirt on underneath!
我里面没穿衬衫！
So what? You have a sweatshirt on.
那又怎样？你穿了一件卫衣。
[INAUDIBLE] I'm not a whore.
[听不清] 我不是妓女。
OK, good.
好吧，很好。
The officer arrests her and her boyfriend and puts them both in the same cop car. And host Dan Abrams gives this commentary at the end.
警官逮捕了她和她的男友，把他们都塞进了同一辆警车。主持人 Dan Abrams 在最后做了点评。
It seems those who steal together stay together. And they're together now in the back seat of that car, both with outstanding warrants.
看来那些一起偷东西的人会待在一起。他们现在在一起坐在那辆车的后座上，都有未执行的逮捕令。
And that's it. We don't see her again in the episode.
就是这样。我们在那一集里没再见到她。
Let's go to Richland County in South Carolina.
让我们去南卡罗来纳州的里奇兰县。
Do you remember it at all?
你完全记得吗？
Just bits and pieces.
只有零星片段。
We met Amy at her parents' home on a street that dead ends at the Spokane River. Amy doesn't ask us in. We sit and talk on a couple lawn chairs in the front yard. It's still patched with melting snow.
我们在 Amy 父母家的前院遇到了她，那条街终点是斯波坎河。Amy 没有让我们进屋。我们在前院的几把草坪椅上坐着谈话。地上还零星铺着融化的雪。
That afternoon, I remember having a drink. And I'm a drinker, obviously. And I have no recollection after this, just, cup of alcohol.
那天下午，我记得喝了一杯酒。显然，我是个酒鬼。此后我就没有任何记忆了，就只记得那杯酒。
Do you remember the cop showing up?
你记得警察出现吗？
No.
不记得。
Literally do not remember it.
真的完全不记得。
No, I have no fucking clue.
不，我他妈完全没头绪。
Do you remember the cops picking you up and helping you out of that house? Do you remember walking through the snow?
你记得警察扶你走出那个房子吗？你记得走过雪地吗？
I don't even remember them reading me my rights.
我甚至不记得他们宣读我的权利。
You saw the cameras.
你看到了摄像头。
I have no recollection of that whole time frame, gentlemen.
各位，我对那整段时间都没有任何记忆。
Don't even remember the cameras.
连摄像头都不记得。
Mm-mm. I didn't start actually really remembering things until I was in booking. I woke up in booking. And I guess I had a mask on my face and--
嗯-嗯。直到我在办案中心才真正开始记起事情。我在办案中心醒来。我想我脸上戴着面罩，因为——
A what?
什么？
A mask on my face because I guess I was spitting. And it was just really embarrassing, you know?
我脸上戴着面罩，因为我想我当时在吐口水。这真的很尴尬，你知道吗？
Can I ask you, I mean, is that something that happens? Have you blacked out before? Often? You don't have to answer that if you don't want to. I'm just--
我能问你吗，我是说，这是常有的事吗？你以前晕倒过吗？经常吗？如果你不想回答可以不回答。我只是——
Not often. Probably like the fourth time I blacked out, and the police were around.
不经常。大概是第四次晕倒时警察在场。
Question-- how does someone that drunk-- blackout drunk-- consent to being on Live PD, a live television show? I mean, it's hard enough for the show Cops to get them to sign, and that's taped months in advance.
问题来了——一个喝得那么醉——断片式醉酒的人——怎么能同意在《Live PD》这样一个直播电视节目上出现？我是说，连《Cops》节目都很难让他们签字，而且那还是提前几个月录制的。
So did you consent?
所以你同意了吗？
No. Obviously not.
没有。显然没有。
Did they talk to you about the fact that you were on television?
他们跟你谈过你正在上电视的事吗？
The police?
警察？
Yeah.
是的。
No.
没有。
So this is the first thing we figure out. Whereas pretty much any other reality show needs the consent of people who appear on their show, Live PD makes a different case. Because it's live, or close to live-- they're actually on a delay. It's somewhere between 10 and 40 minutes. But because it's live, Live PD says, hey, we're basically news. And news doesn't need consent from suspects, so why should we? At least that's what they've argued in court. So for people like Amy, there is no consent involved here. You're on the show whether you like it or not. They don't blur her face, nothing.
所以这是我们弄清楚的第一件事。虽然几乎所有其他真人秀都需要出现的人同意，但《Live PD》的情况不同。因为它是在直播，或接近直播——实际上有延迟。大概在 10 到 40 分钟之间。但因为它是在直播，《Live PD》说，嘿，我们基本就是新闻。新闻不需要嫌疑人的同意，那我们为什么需要？至少他们在法庭上是这样辩称的。所以对于 Amy 这样的人来说，这里根本不涉及同意问题。不管你喜不喜欢，你都在节目上。他们没有模糊她的脸，什么都没有。
Another thing we learned about Live PD and Cops, too, is that the police approve everything that goes on the air. With Live PD, that's where that 10- to 40-minute delay comes in. There's actually a hotline set up, like a Batphone, where the sheriffs can see what's about to go out on the air and just pick up the hotline and kill it.
关于《Live PD》和《Cops》，我们还学到的另一件事是，警方批准了所有播出的内容。《Live PD》的 10 到 40 分钟延迟就是为了这个。实际上有一条热线，就像红色电话一样，警长可以看到即将播出的内容，拿起热线直接切断它。
A lot of people watch Live PD. What do you imagine they're watching it for?
很多人看《Live PD》。你想象他们看这个是为了什么？
To watch fucking drunk-ass idiots make fools of themselves, myself-- sorry to be like that, but they are just fucking-- they have no problem belittling you, and humiliating you, and degrading you, just laughing at me and stuff in booking and just-- some of them calling me names.
看一群醉醺醺的傻瓜让自己出丑，我自己——抱歉这么说，但他们确实他妈的——他们毫无顾忌地贬低你、羞辱你、甚至在办案中心嘲笑我，叫我各种名字。
What were they laughing at you for?
他们嘲笑你什么？
Because I had made it on Live PD.
因为我上了《Live PD》。
In fact, by the time Live PD was on again the next night, they had already edited footage of Amy into the opening of the show, a hot mix of the most salacious moments with Amy exclaiming--
事实上，等到第二天晚上《Live PD》再次播出时，他们已经把 Amy 的镜头剪辑进了开场，这成了最火爆的瞬间剪辑，Amy 大喊着——
I have no shirt on underneath.
我里面没穿衬衫。
She is drunk.
她喝醉了。
And what's more, she was afraid her Live PD appearance would just make her look guilty before she even had a trial.
而且更重要的是，她担心她的《Live PD》出镜会让她在还没受审之前看起来就有罪。
Been there for them to say I'm going to jail on a fucking stolen property-- Jesus.
在那里，他们说我要因为该死的持有赃物去坐牢——天呐。
Because now everyone's assuming that you stole property, instead of-- or somebody going--
因为现在每个人都假设你偷了东西，而不是——或者有人去——
Yeah, before I even fucking go to trial. And if I don't beat my trial, thanks a lot, fucking Live PD. Do you understand what I mean? Already, I looked like a piece of shit. That's fucking another nail in my coffin. And it's just like you-- yeah.
是的，在我他妈去受审之前。如果我审判没赢，谢了啊，该死的《Live PD》。你明白我的意思吗？我已经看起来像个渣滓了。那是我棺材上的另一根钉子。这就像你——是的。
Did you ever have any good interactions with the police?
你有没有和警察有过好的互动？
Yes, once. A long time ago, there was a police officer once. I was walking down Empire, and it was winter. I didn't have a coat, no shoes-- just a blanket. And he actually gave me a ride in his car to a battered women's shelter. I never forgot that. They're not all assholes, but the majority of them, yes, are. And it's nothing I would not say to their face.
有，有过一次。很久以前，有一次。我沿着帝国大道走，那是冬天。我没穿外套，没穿鞋——只有一条毯子。他真的开车载我去了受虐妇女收容所。我永远忘不了那次。他们并不都是混蛋，但大多数人确实是。我当面也会这么说。
I'm getting that sense.
我感觉到这一点了。
We would all notice.
我们都会注意到。
You do see good policing on Live PD-- all the time, actually. Cops, too. You see it in big and small ways-- officers being kind to an elderly woman who keeps calling 911 just for company. We found one guy who OD'd on camera, and the cops gave him Narcan, saved his life. There are segments where the police de-escalate situations in ways that seem really impressive. But these shows, they're not designed around those segments. It's not good TV to watch a cop help an old lady across the street.
你确实能在《Live PD》上看到好的警务——实际上一直都能看到。《Cops》也一样。你会在大事小事上看到——警察对一个为了找人聊天而不断拨打 911 的老妇人表现出善意。我们发现有一个人在镜头前过量用药，警察给了他纳洛酮，救了他的命。有些片段中警察以看起来非常令人印象深刻的方式缓解了局势。但这些节目，并不是围绕这些片段设计的。看警察扶老太太过马路在电视上可不好看。
Over the past five years, body cameras have been adopted by police departments across the country. The idea being simple-- if there's a body cam recording your every move, it will encourage good policing. But what about a TV camera? Does that encourage good policing, or does it encourage the police to make good TV?
过去五年里，执法记录仪被全国的警察局采用。想法很简单——如果有记录你一举一动的执法记录仪，就会鼓励良好的警务。但电视摄像机呢？那会鼓励良好的警务，还是会鼓励警察拍出好看的电视节目？
Amy had a friend who was also filmed by Live PD who felt the cops had gone after her not just as police, but as police trying to make a compelling TV show.
Amy 有个朋友也被《Live PD》拍摄过，她觉得警察追捕她不仅仅是作为警察，而是作为试图制作引人入胜电视节目的警察。
I went to jail, then my friend went fucking the week later.
我进了监狱，然后我朋友一周后也进去了。
How far are we now from where that was?
我们现在离那时候有多远？
In a car? Like, probably 5, 10 minutes.
开车？大概 5 到 10 分钟。
Super close.
超级近。
So we go. A few miles away, we find the house that Jessica is staying at right now. It's her mom's place.
所以我们去了。几英里外，我们找到了 Jessica 现在待的房子。那是她妈妈的地方。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声音]
Hi, nice to meet you. I'm Jessica. How are you going?
嗨，很高兴见到你。我是 Jessica。你们好吗？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声音]
I just got out of jail this morning, and my mom was moving without me.
我今天早上刚从监狱出来，我妈妈就要搬家了。
Jessica's hair is wet. She just got out of the shower. Thick ropes of cigarette smoke snake around the room. She's welcoming and a little frazzled, given the day she's already had.
Jessica 的头发是湿的。她刚洗完澡。厚厚的香烟烟雾在房间里盘旋。考虑到她这一天，她很热情，但也有些精疲力竭。
I just got out. Like I said, I just got off the transport after a three-hour drive this morning, and was in booking from Benton County Jail.
我刚出来。就像我说的，我今天早上坐了三个小时的运输车刚下来，一直在本顿县监狱办理入监。
Jessica's had a rough go. She's an addict, has been for a while. And turns out, Jessica has had more than one run-in with the Live PD cameras.
Jessica 经历很坎坷。她是瘾君子，已经有一段时间了。事实证明，Jessica 不止一次撞上了《Live PD》的摄像头。
The second time was December 21.
第二次是 12 月 21 日。
You were on it more than once?
你上过不止一次？
Yeah, well, they always [INAUDIBLE] film.
是的，好吧，他们总是 [听不清] 拍摄。
She thinks she's being targeted in a way that she wouldn't be if the police didn't have cameras following them. Which leads us to the other thing we find out. Live PD, not totally live. They hedge their bets. They actually send crews out at all hours, filming arrests and banking them. So if it's a slow night of policing, they can just slap one of those on the air, and say it's earlier. Like this.
她认为自己被针对了，如果警察没有摄像头跟随他们，就不会这样。这引出了我们发现的另一件事。《Live PD》并不完全是直播。他们留了后手。他们实际上会在所有时间派出摄制组，拍摄逮捕过程并存起来。所以如果是一个警务冷清的晚上，他们可以直接把其中的一个放出来，说那是早些时候发生的。就像这样。
We want to show you something that happened earlier in Spokane County, Washington.
我们想向你们展示一些早些时候在华盛顿州斯波坎县发生的事情。
The implication is earlier today, right? Like a couple hours ago? Jessica's arrest happened over three weeks before it aired. Here's how Jessica's Live PD appearance went down. This is Live PD, season 1, episode 57.
暗示是今天早些时候，对吧？比如几个小时前？Jessica 的逮捕发生在她播出前三周多。这是 Jessica 在《Live PD》的出镜过程。这是《Live PD》第 1 季第 57 集。
Deputies went to serve a warrant on a woman they've dealt with many times before.
副警长去为一个他们以前处理过很多次的女人执行逮捕令。
They cut to a cop car. It's nighttime.
他们切换到警车。是晚上。
So, right now, we're just going to a female that is wanted by department of corrections on a warrant. We know her very well. She has an extensive history with us. So we're just going to go to her mom's house, where she might be at, see if she's there.
所以，现在，我们正要去一个被矫正部门通缉的女性那里。我们很了解她。她有很长的历史。所以我们要去她妈妈家，看看她是不是在那儿。
Don't let that horror movie music fool you, by the way. That warrant is for a low-level offense, basically for missing a date with her corrections officer. So, she's not an ax murderer. I'll let Jessica narrate the rest.
顺便说一句，别被那恐怖片的音乐骗了。那个逮捕令是因为轻微罪行，基本是因为错过了与缓刑监督官的约会。所以，她不是个连环杀手。我让 Jessica 叙述其余部分。
We were sitting here smoking a bowl of meth in my mom's driveway right here. We get our stuff together. We're driving down the driveway, and there's a cop.
我们当时正坐在我妈妈的车道上抽冰毒。我们收拾好东西。我们正开出车道，就有一个警察。
So she runs and hides in the bushes, but the cops brought the dog, who sniffed her out.
所以她跑去躲在灌木丛里，但警察带了狗，把她嗅了出来。
Sheriff's office, stop.
治安官办公室，停下。
And all of a sudden, boom. I'm lit up by big camera lights, the dog, three cops. And that's where you'll see the footage that they actually showed.
突然，轰。我被巨大的摄像灯、狗、三个警察照亮了。那就是你会看到他们实际播出的镜头。
You're under arrest.
你被捕了。
[INAUDIBLE] today.
[听不清] 今天。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声音]
I'm [INAUDIBLE] dog [INAUDIBLE].
我是 [听不清] 狗 [听不清]。
This dog?
这只狗？
I was like, hey, man, don't let the dog bite me. If you watch the footage, you can see that I'm pretty afraid of the dog.
我当时心想，嘿，伙计，别让狗咬我。如果你看镜头，你会发现我当时非常怕那只狗。
Please don't let him. I'm not moving.
请别让他。我没动。
Don't move.
别动。
I'm not. Promise.
我没动。我保证。
She stands up out of the bushes, hands up, and she's got no top on. She's in her bra. She pulled her shirt off because it was bright orange, and she thought it might give her away.
她从灌木丛里站起来，举起双手，身上没穿上衣。她只穿着文胸。她把衬衫扯了下来，因为它太亮了，她以为这会暴露她。
For these earlier-on segments, the ones that aren't aired live, Live PD, from what we can tell actually does try to get consent from suspects.
对于这些早期的片段，那些不是直播的，据我们所知，《Live PD》确实试图获得嫌疑人的同意。
Jessica said no. But that doesn't mean they won't use it. They'll just blur your face. So Jessica's face is blurred, but nothing else is. All the cops are kind of smirking, and smiling at her.
Jessica 说了不。但这并不意味着他们不会用。他们只是模糊了你的脸。所以 Jessica 的脸被模糊了，但其他什么都没有。所有的警察都有点在笑，微笑着看她。
Keep moving.
继续走。
This is all over DOC?
这都是因为矫正部？
Yeah, crazy.
是的，疯了。
[INAUDIBLE] around. I'm sorry. I've been running because I was thinking you guys, I'm in trouble for something different. My bad.
[听不清] 四处走动。我很抱歉。我一直在跑，因为我以为你们是因为别的事情来抓我。我的错。
What did you think you were in trouble for? Kill somebody we don't know about? She was hiding in the back of her mom's house.
你以为是因为什么事？杀了我们不知道的人吗？她躲在她妈妈房子后面。
Her face was blurred, but she was still recognized on the show by friends and by a niece who lives 300 miles away. But Jessica's biggest complaint about all this is how relentless the police were in trying to get her on camera. Fine. If they want to serve her a warrant, she's dealt with the police before. But they seemed dead-set on serving her that warrant on TV. They came again, and again.
她的脸模糊了，但她还是在节目中被朋友和远在 300 英里外的一个侄女认出来了。但 Jessica 对这一切最大的抱怨是警察在试图让她上镜时是多么无情。好吧。如果他们想给她发逮捕令，她以前处理过警察。但他们似乎铁了心要在电视上给她送那个逮捕令。他们来了又来。
They've came to my mom's house. I could-- let me call my mom real quick and I'll ask her, we can probably-- I can put it on speaker and you guys can hear how many times they came here with the dog, with the cameras, beating down the door at 1:30, 2:00 in the morning.
他们来了我妈家。我能——让我赶紧给我妈打个电话，我问问她，我们可能——我可以开扬声器，你们就能听到他们拿着狗、拿着摄像机，在凌晨 1:30、2:00 砸门来了多少次。
When my mom goes to work, my daughter is in the 7th grade, and goes to school, and is a wonderful student and athlete. And beating down the door like I'm some pistol-toting, dope-dealing, assault rifle-carrying badass bitch. And that's not me.
我妈去上班的时候，我女儿正在上 7 年级，是个出色的学生和运动员。他们像我是个持枪、贩毒、携带突击步枪的坏蛋荡妇一样砸门。那不是我。
Jessica gets her mom on the phone.
Jessica 给她妈妈打了电话。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Mom?
妈？
Yeah.
嗯。
Hi, hey. Real quick, you're being recorded, just so you know.
嗨，快说。你正在被录音，只是让你知道。
OK.
好吧。
How many times would you figure that Live PD and the cops came over here looking for me since July?
你觉得自从七月以来《Live PD》和警察来这儿找我多少次了？
Uh, probably 6. Probably about six times.
呃，可能有 6 次。大概六次左右。
Six times, with cameras?
六次，带着摄像机？
Yes.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
It's ridiculous.
太荒谬了。
So you think you're targeted?
所以你觉得你被针对了？
Oh, beyond. Oh, absolutely.
噢，何止。绝对是。
I worked as a producer on a live television show once, and I'll never do it again. The pressure is truly nauseating, and dead air is not an option. And Live PD has got six hours live every week. You've got to fill it with something. Would it be that surprising if the police did target her, all for some dumb TV show? Listen to what one of the officers said about her on the scene.
我曾经在直播电视节目做过制作人，我再也不会那么做了。压力真的让人反胃，而且死气沉沉的直播是不被允许的。而《Live PD》每周有六个小时的直播。你必须用某种东西填满它。如果警察真的针对她，只是为了那个愚蠢的电视节目，会很令人惊讶吗？听听其中一个警察在现场是怎么说她的。
She's tripping a bit right now. She's a frequent flyer that we know very well. She's been arrested lots and lots for this kind of thing.
她现在有点迷糊。她是个我们很熟的“常客”。因为这种事她被捕过很多次了。
Oh my god.
天呐。
They know Jessica. Spokane is a small city. They know all about her.
他们认识 Jessica。斯波坎是个小城市。他们很了解她。
I'm pretty entertaining, I guess. You know, like if I keep them laughing, and everything seems to go a little bit smoother. And I have a really good sense of humor, so.
我想我挺有趣的吧。你知道，如果我能让他们笑，一切似乎就会顺利一点。而且我真的很有幽默感，所以。
She does, actually. Jessica is charming. She's funny. And she's quick. And if the police deal with her as much as they say they do, they'd know that, too. After her arrest was all over one officer, even says--
她确实，很有趣。Jessica 有魅力。她很滑稽。而且很快。如果警察像他们说的那样经常和她打交道，他们也会知道这一点。在她被捕后，甚至有一个警察说——
She's a hoot. Oh, yeah.
她真是个活宝。噢，是的。
She's a hoot. In other words, she's good TV. And she was. She was weird, and wacky, and she had no top on.
她真是个活宝。换句话说，她是个很好的电视素材。确实如此。她很怪，很古怪，而且没穿上衣。
You know, just because I'm having a bad month, or a bad year, or a bad week, doesn't mean that they can take my face, and my name, and call me a frequent flyer, like they said. I might be a washed-out junkie, but I've got a good soul and a good personality, and, you know.
你知道，仅仅因为我过了一个糟糕的月、糟糕的一年或糟糕的一周，并不意味着他们可以拿走我的脸、我的名字，叫我“常客”，就像他们说的那样。我可能是一个落魄的瘾君子，但我有个好的灵魂和好的个性，而且，你知道的。
The Spokane sheriff's office says they didn't target Jessica because she would make good TV. They went after her multiple times because she had a warrant. They say it's not uncommon. Quote, "That was true before Live PD was here, and it's still true today."
斯波坎治安官办公室表示他们并没有因为 Jessica 会成为好的电视素材而针对她。他们多次追捕她是因为她有逮捕令。他们说这并不罕见。引用：“这在《Live PD》来到这里之前就是事实，今天依然如此。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
In March of last year, the city council in Spokane decided that they had had enough, that citizens were being forced onto the show unwillingly. But also, and a little more practically, it just didn't make the city look that good on national television. They voted 5 to 1 to effectively kick Live PD and Cops out of the city limits.
去年三月，斯波坎市议会决定他们受够了，公民被迫无奈地出现在节目中。但从更现实的角度来看，它让这座城市在全国电视上看起来并不太好。他们以 5 比 1 的投票结果有效地将《Live PD》和《Cops》赶出了城市范围。
Other cities that have rethought their participation in Live PD-- Bridgeport, Connecticut, Streetsboro, Ohio, and Tulsa, Oklahoma. The pushback doesn't seem to be slowing Live PD down, though. In fact, last fall A&E ordered more episodes of the show. But not like 13 or 26 episodes like a network normally would. They ordered 450 more hours of it.
其他重新考虑参与《Live PD》的城市——康涅狄格州布里奇波特、俄亥俄州 Streetsboro 和俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨。不过，抵制似乎并没有放慢《Live PD》的速度。事实上，去年秋天 A&E 预定了更多剧集。但不是像电视网通常那样 13 或 26 集。他们又预定了 450 小时的节目。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Dan Taberski. His podcast is called Running from Cops. It's made by Pineapple Street Media. The producers of Live PD did not respond to Dan and his team when they reached out. And we also reached out. We tried to do some fact-checking with them. They did not answer our fact check questions, but did issue a statement asserting the rights to broadcast what they do live.
Dan Taberski。他的播客叫《Running from Cops》。由 Pineapple Street Media 制作。《Live PD》的制作人在 Dan 和他的团队联系时没有做出回应。我们也联系了。我们试图和他们进行了一些事实核查。他们没有回答我们的核查问题，但发表了一份声明，声称直播他们所做内容的权利。
Quote, "The First Amendment protects the right of the media to record people involved in public places in matters of public interest, which certainly includes the actions of law enforcement."
引用：“第一修正案保护媒体记录公共利益事件中公共场所涉及人员的权利，其中当然包括执法部门的行为。”
Coming up on TV, but there is no way you could ever know it, because you don't know what TV is. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来在电视上，但你永远无法知道，因为你不知道电视是什么。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, I'm on TV. Stories of people who are used to being on the watching side of television, the normal side of television, who suddenly, without choosing, are placed on the other side of the screen. Or maybe the best way to say that is they're inside the screen. I don't know.
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我在电视上”。讲述那些习惯于站在电视旁、电视正常那一侧的人，突然在没有选择的情况下被置于屏幕另一侧的故事。或者说最好的说法是他们被置于屏幕之内。我不知道。
What's that do to you? We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "Born To Play The Part." I know somebody who whenever we would watch a film or TV show, if there was a dog in the scene, they always did the same thing-- they would turn to me and say, dog doesn't know it's in a movie. Or dog doesn't know that's Mel Gibson. Dog doesn't know that Neil Patrick Harris. Same thing if a baby showed up. Baby doesn't know that's Meryl Streep. Baby doesn't know it's in a film.
那对你有什么影响？我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“生来就扮演这个角色”。我认识一个人，每当我们看电影或电视节目时，如果场景里有一只狗，他们总是做同样的事——他们会转向我说，狗不知道它在电影里。或者狗不知道那是 Mel Gibson。狗不知道那是 Neil Patrick Harris。如果出现个婴儿也是一样。婴儿不知道那是 Meryl Streep。婴儿不知道它在电影里。
One of our producers, Bim Adewunmi, is also a big noticer or of babies on television, including one in particular that she's become slightly obsessed with. Here's Bim.
我们的制作人之一 Bim Adewunmi 也是个大婴儿关注者，包括她变得有点着迷的一个特定婴儿。这是 Bim。
OK. So it's an uncharacteristically peaceful scene in the sixth season of The Walking Dead. No zombies, no gore. There's a man, the hero of the show, Rick Grimes and his teenage son Carl. The whole scene has a cloud of awkward family tension, but nothing more perilous than that.
好吧。所以这是《行尸走肉》第六季中一个罕见的平静场景。没有僵尸，没有血腥。有一个人，节目的英雄 Rick Grimes 和他十几岁的儿子 Carl。整个场景有一层尴尬的家庭紧张感，但没有比这更危险的了。
Get your stuff. Gabriel can take care of Judith while we're gone.
拿好你的东西。我们离开时 Gabriel 可以照顾 Judith。
I'm not coming.
我不去。
But wait. There's a third character in the scene. She's wearing a lilac smock dress, and she's got a pacifier in her mouth. She's a baby, and she's adorable. Her name is Judith. So anyway, Rick is carrying Judith towards Carl in the street. And as they approach, the baby spots the teen and she waves. It's obviously unscripted, because how could you script a toddler?
但等等。场景中还有第三个角色。她穿着一件丁香色的罩衫裙，嘴里叼着个安抚奶嘴。她是个婴儿，她很可爱。她的名字叫 Judith。总之，Rick 正抱着 Judith 在街上向 Carl 走去。当他们靠近时，婴儿发现了这个少年并挥手。这显然不是写在剧本里的，因为你怎么能给蹒跚学步的孩子写剧本呢？
And you can see the actor playing her dad, Andrew Lincoln, look down and smile in surprise. All through the scene Judy goes through baby's greatest hits. She fidgets. She sucks on her pacifier. She makes sounds that the subtitles caption as babbling. And with one arm wrapped around Rick's bicep, she swivels her head back and forth, just observing her environment.
你可以看到饰演她父亲的演员 Andrew Lincoln 低头惊讶地微笑。在整个场景中，Judy 经历了婴儿最精彩的瞬间。她坐立不安。她吮吸着安抚奶嘴。她发出字幕标注为“咿呀学语”的声音。一只手臂环绕着 Rick 的二头肌，她来回旋转着头，只是观察着她的环境。
And then she does the one thing you're not supposed to do. She spots the camera, and then proceeds very happily to break the fourth wall. She stares, and I mean stares down the barrel of the camera. Her focus, laser-sharp. Above her head, acting with a capital A, is happening. This is the highest-rated cable show in America.
然后她做了你绝对不该做的一件事。她发现了摄像机，然后很开心地打破了第四面墙。她盯着，我是说盯着摄像机的镜头。她的焦点，激光般锐利。在她头顶上，正在发生着大写的“演戏”。这是美国收视率最高的有线电视节目。
But to this baby, who knows nothing about craft, or dramaturgy, or anything else or the televisual arts, there's only a great big camera. And as far as she understands life, it's there to be looked at. A few things go through my mind whenever I watch this scene.
但对这个不知道手艺、戏剧学或其他任何电视艺术的婴儿来说，只有一台巨大的摄像机。就她对生活的理解而言，它是用来被观看的。每当我看到这个场景时，会有一些想法闪过脑海。
That this must have been the best take of the day. I don't know why, but that tickles me. The idea of a Hollywood set being at the mercy of a baby's whims is just joyous to me. Judith has been around on the show since the third season, the first baby born to our heroes since the dead began roaming the Earth. The parade of babies who played her in seasons 3 to 5 were fine.
这一定是当天拍得最好的一条。我不知道为什么，但这让我很高兴。好莱坞片场受婴儿心血来潮摆布的想法对我来说真是太快乐了。Judith 从第三季开始就在节目中出现了，这是自从死者开始在地球上游荡以来，我们英雄中出生的第一个婴儿。在第三季到第五季中饰演她的婴儿阵列都很好。
But the Judith they cast in season 6, ah, the platonic ideal of cute baby. Cheeks, heavy and jowly. Mouth rosebud. Eyes wide and bright. Can a baby have charisma? Well, this baby had charisma. First of all, she was a surprisingly good actor sometimes.
但他们在第六季选角的 Judith，啊，可爱婴儿的柏拉图式理想。脸颊，沉重而丰满。嘴唇如玫瑰花蕾。眼睛又大又亮。婴儿能有魅力吗？嗯，这个婴儿有魅力。首先，她有时是个出人意料的好演员。
Take season 6, episode 9, "No Way Out."
看第六季第 9 集，“没有出路”。
All right. New plan.
好的。新计划。
Judith, along with her parents and brother, are trying to escape a herd of walkers who have broken into their community. The thing is, walkers can smell humans. And so the survivors have to mask their scent by wearing sheets smeared in Walker guts to get through the horde.
Judith 和她的父母及兄弟正试图逃离一群闯入他们社区的行尸。问题是，行尸能闻到人类的味道。所以幸存者必须通过穿上涂抹了行尸内脏的床单来遮盖他们的气味，以穿过那群行尸。
Eventually, the group is forced to split up, and Judy gets passed from her brother, who's carrying her under his sheet, to another member of the group.
最终，小组被迫分开，Judy 被从抱着她的兄弟那里转移给小组的另一个成员。
I'll take her.
我来带她。
There's a tight shot of Judy's little face as she gets transferred, fake blood on her cheek. And she looks 100% stressed out, like she's thinking, for god's sake, what now? And of course she thinks that. Look around her. It's all zombies. She's not acting at all, which of course makes her the best actor in the scene. Talk about method. We get Judith in short bursts, mere seconds at a time. I've inadvertently watched her grow up. In the first episode of season 9, she talks.
当她被转移时，有一个 Judy 小脸的特写镜头，脸上带着假血。她看起来 100% 压力巨大，好像在想，看在上帝的份上，现在又怎么了？当然她会那样想。看看她周围。到处都是僵尸。她根本没有在演戏，这当然使她成为场景中最好的演员。谈谈方法派表演。我们只在短时间内得到 Judith 的镜头，每次仅几秒钟。我不经意间看着她长大。在第九季的第一集中，她会说话了。
[CHILD BABBLING]
[婴儿咿呀学语]
Judith is actually played by two babies. That tends to be the case because of pesky things like labor laws and child welfare. You can swap out one identical twin for another without messing up continuity. The twins that play Judith, their names are Sofia and Chloe Garcia-Frizzi.
Judith 实际上是由两个婴儿扮演的。因为像劳动法和儿童福利这种讨厌的东西，情况往往如此。你可以替换一个一模一样的双胞胎而不破坏连续性。饰演 Judith 的双胞胎名字叫 Sofia 和 Chloe Garcia-Frizzi。
I cannot stress this enough. The Garcia-Frizzi twins might be the cutest babies I have ever seen, on telly or in real life. Top three, definitely. They arrived in their butterball prime, all round and squishy. No hard edges to them. And now they are five years old.
我怎么强调都不为过。Garcia-Frizzi 双胞胎可能是我在电视上或现实生活中见过最可爱的婴儿。前三名，绝对的。她们正处于婴儿肥的鼎盛期，圆润柔软。身上没有坚硬的边缘。现在她们五岁了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It's funny to think of babies as famous, as being recognized by fans in the streets. Because being a baby, you're often the center of attention. You have someone who prepares your food and drives you around. It's not so different from being famous. There's no way a baby would know they were getting special attention.
把婴儿当成名人，在街上被粉丝认出来是很有趣的。因为作为婴儿，你往往是关注的焦点。你有准备食物和开车送你的人。这和出名没什么两样。婴儿不可能知道他们受到了特别关注。
Babies just expect that. I talked to the Garcia-Frizzi twins' mother, Tiffany, to ask if the girls knew they were famous now that they're five.
婴儿只是期待那样。我和 Garcia-Frizzi 双胞胎的母亲 Tiffany 谈过，问孩子们在五岁时是否知道她们出名了。
It's actually really, really funny, because until my oldest daughter told them that they were famous, they legitimately did not now. Like they would go up to kids at the park, and they'd ask them what TV show they're on. And it's like, no not everybody's on a TV show.
其实真的很有趣，因为直到我大女儿告诉她们她们很有名之前，她们真的不知道。就像她们在公园里走向孩子们，问他们上什么电视节目。就像是，不，不是每个人都上电视节目。
So until their older sister was like no, you guys are on TV. You're famous. They're like, what's famous? I was like, it means nothing. It means nothing.
所以直到她们的大姐说“不，你们上电视了。你们出名了”。她们问“出名是什么？”我说，这毫无意义。这毫无意义。
They get recognized from time to time, like when they went trick or treating and the people at the house were dressed like characters from "The Walking Dead."
她们时不时会被认出来，比如她们去“不给糖就捣蛋”时，房子里的人打扮得像《行尸走肉》里的角色。
I think they're starting to come aware of, like, that other people do know who they are that aren't necessarily people we know, if that makes sense. Like, strangers know who they are. I don't think they really necessarily connected it to fame yet.
我想她们开始意识到，有些人知道她们是谁，但不一定是我们认识的人，如果这说得通的话。就像，陌生人知道她们是谁。我不认为她们真正地把这和名气联系起来。
But they will tell people they're Judith Grimes. Like, they definitely know that they play pretend on TV. But they don't know it's acting. They just think it's pretend.
但她们会告诉别人她们是 Judith Grimes。就像，她们绝对知道她们在电视上玩角色扮演。但她们不知道那是在演戏。她们只是觉得那是假装。
Fame changes us, takes us further away from what we once were, which is to say innocent and pure. Famous babies don't know they're famous, so they're immune to its dangers. When you think about it, babies are the only beings who should be famous.
名气改变了我们，把我们带离了曾经的我们，也就是天真和纯洁。出名的婴儿不知道他们出名了，所以他们对名气的危险免疫。当你仔细想想，婴儿是唯一应该出名的存在。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
Bim Adewunmi 是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act 3, "Lina with an N." So we now turn to two girls. One of them has this big moment in her life end up on national television, and she had no choice about that. The other sees that moment on television, and it sticks with her for years.
第三幕，“Lina，拼写是 N”。所以我们现在转向两个女孩。其中一个在她生命中这个巨大时刻登上了全国电视，她对此别无选择。另一个在电视上看到了那一刻，并且在几年里一直萦绕在心头。
The second girl in the story is Lina Misitzis, one of the producers of our show. A piece of background you need to know to understand this story-- she was really into musical theater as a kid. Listened to musicals, fantasized about being in them, which is why this story stayed with her. Here she is.
故事里的第二个女孩是 Lina Misitzis，我们节目的制作人之一。你需要了解一点背景才能理解这个故事——她小时候非常迷恋音乐剧。听音乐剧，幻想身处其中，这就是为什么这个故事一直萦绕在她心头。在这里。
I know when it started. It was in Greece-- the country, not the musical. I spent part of my childhood there. I was six or seven years old when I found a two-disk CD set at the bottom of some sales bin, a best of Broadway compilation from various European tours of Broadway shows, all in different languages. I remember a German "I Am What I Am" from "La Cage aux Folles."
我知道它是从什么时候开始的。是在希腊——那个国家，不是那部音乐剧。我童年的一部分在那里度过。我六七岁时，在某个特价箱底部找到了一套双碟 CD，是一套来自不同百老汇演出欧洲巡演的百老汇精选集，都是不同语言的。我记得《La Cage aux Folles》（一笼傻鸟）里德语版的“I Am What I Am”（我就是我）。
[MUSIC - "I AM WHAT I AM']
[音乐 - “I AM WHAT I AM”]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[非英语演唱]
I listened over and over, arms outstretched, pretending I was onstage, spotlit.
我一遍又一遍地听，双臂伸展，假装我在舞台上，处于聚光灯下。
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[非英语演唱]
It only escalated from there. Back in America, in my bedroom in Virginia, I Scotch-taped up pictures of Ethel Merman, Bernadette Peters, Bebe Neuwirth. On weekends, I checked casting calls in the Washington Post. My mom's rule was if an audition was less than five miles away, I could try out. I recorded the Tonys on VHS each year, watched it over and over.
此后一发不可收拾。回到美国，在我弗吉尼亚的卧室里，我用透明胶带贴上了 Ethel Merman、Bernadette Peters、Bebe Neuwirth 的照片。周末，我会查看《华盛顿邮报》上的选角通告。我妈妈的规矩是，如果试镜地点在五英里之内，我就可以尝试。我每年都用录像带录下托尼奖，一遍又一遍地看。
Same for "Sound Of Music" and "Fiddler on the Roof." But the tape I watched the most, the one that spoke to me more than any other, was this 1997 TV special. Barbara Walters hosted, and it was called "Broadway's New Annie: Search For A Star." and if the title doesn't give it away, here's the premise. The musical "Annie" was coming back to Broadway and the show's director needed to find a star. And this was how he decided to do it, on TV.
《音乐之声》和《屋顶上的小提琴手》也一样。但我看的最多的录像带，对我说话最多的，是 1997 年的这个电视特辑。Barbara Walters 主持的，叫《百老汇的新安妮：寻找明星》。如果标题没说明一切，前提就是这样。音乐剧《安妮》要重返百老汇，导演需要找一个明星。这就是他决定做的方式，在电视上。
Little girls, little girls, 2,000 little girls all sharing the same dream.
小女孩，小女孩，2000 个小女孩都怀着同一个梦想。
Annie, Annie, Annie, Annie, Annie.
安妮，安妮，安妮，安妮，安妮。
I was 8, the same age as those girls. I could have auditioned if I'd known about it. It was a nationwide contest sponsored by the department store Macy's, and there was a Macy's less than five miles from my house. To watch, I dressed up like an orphan, and the closest thing I came up with was wearing my older brother's underwear.
我当时 8 岁，和那些女孩一样大。如果我知道的话我也可以去试镜。这是一个由梅西百货赞助的全国性竞赛，离我家不到五英里就有一家梅西百货。为了观看，我装扮成孤儿，我能想到的最接近的东西是穿上我哥哥的内衣。
I'd stand in front of the TV transfixed, so close my mom would yell at me that I was going to damage my eyes. And the person I was watching for was this one girl named Harley who reminded me of me because she was special, perfect for the role in every way, which I figured I'd be. Although Harley had the advantage of also looking the part-- long red wavy hair, chubby cheeks. The sort of aw, shucks grin you want to see on Annie's face. Except.
我会站在电视机前出神，离得那么近，我妈妈会对我大喊我会弄坏眼睛。我一直在观察的那个人是一个叫 Harley 的女孩，她让我想起我自己，因为她很特别，在各方面都很适合这个角色，我想我会是那样的。尽管 Harley 还有看起来很像这个角色的优势——长长的红色波浪卷发，肉嘟嘟的脸颊。那种你想在安妮脸上看到的“啊，哎呀”的咧嘴笑。除了。
But then, it was Harley's turn to sing.
但后来，轮到 Harley 唱歌了。
(SINGING) Tomorrow.
(演唱) 明天。
I don't want you to do that. You're going tomorrow, tomorrow. Tomorrow! Too! Loud! (SINGING) Too.
我不想让你那样做。你要唱明天，明天。明天！太！响了！(演唱) 太。
(SINGING) Too.
(演唱) 太。
Too. Too. Too! Too!
太。太。太！太！
Just sometimes, I get kind of scared, and it was really scary. So it kind of like came out.
有时候，我感到有点害怕，而且真的很吓人。所以它就像那样出来了。
She's scared, which is kind of understandable. The guy she's auditioning for is Martin Charnin. He wrote "Annie" back in 1976. He was the show's original director. That's him you hear singing along with her. Martin takes Harley by the hand, and leads her away from all the other girls.
她很害怕，这是可以理解的。她试镜的对象是 Martin Charnin。他在 1976 年写了《安妮》。他是该剧最初的导演。你听到和他一起唱歌的就是他。Martin 牵着 Harley 的手，把她带离了其他女孩。
He cups her chin in his palm, and places her on the floor by his feet, and together they watch more Annie hopefuls audition.
他用手心捧着她的下巴，把她放在他脚边的地板上，他们一起观看更多安妮候选人的试镜。
Then I sat with the director, and then he let me watch.
然后我和导演坐在一起，他让我看。
So 149 was singing with you, right?
所以 149 号在和你一起唱歌，对吧？
Something about the little girl's face makes Martin want to see her again. She makes the finals.
那个小女孩的脸让 Martin 想再见她一次。她进入了决赛。
I'm just going to think about just smile, and do your best.
我只想想想微笑，尽力而为。
I loved this story because Harley just needed to be noticed by the right person, just like I needed.
我喜欢这个故事，因为 Harley 只需要被对的人注意到，就像我也需要的那样。
August 7, at a nondescript rehearsal hall in Midtown Manhattan, the finalists have gathered selected from 2,000 of the last auditions. Harley Ott, one of Martin's favorites, is back from Jersey. She has another chance to sing, but again is struck with stage fright.
8 月 7 日，在曼哈顿中城一个不起眼的排练厅里，决赛选手汇集在一起，是从 2000 个最后试镜中挑选出来的。Martin 的最爱之一 Harley Ott 从泽西岛回来了。她有另一次唱歌的机会，但再次被舞台恐惧感袭击。
(SINGING) You're always a day [INAUDIBLE].
(演唱) 你永远是一天 [听不清]。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Day a-
一天——
A-
啊——
It doesn't go well, and still, later that day she gets a third chance.
进行得不顺利，尽管如此，那天晚些时候她得到了第三次机会。
Martin, who thinks she might be right for the role of an orphan, still believes he could overcome her nerves in rehearsal.
Martin 认为她可能适合演孤儿这个角色，仍然相信他能在排练中克服她的紧张。
OK, so now she's out of the running for Annie. But she may become an orphan on Broadway-- the kind of thing I'd have died for. As far as I was concerned, Harley had made it. But then comes the moment I haven't been able to understand for more than 20 years. As a kid I found it upsetting, as an adult baffling. Martin walks into the hall to grab Harley.
好吧，现在她失去了演安妮的机会。但她可能会成为百老汇的一个孤儿——那种我会为之去死的事情。就我而言，Harley 成功了。但随后发生了我 20 多年来一直无法理解的时刻。小时候我觉得它令人不安，成年后觉得它令人困惑。Martin 走进大厅去抓 Harley。
Is Harley here?
Harley 在这儿吗？
But when he goes to find her parents.
但他去找她父母时。
Brian, where did Harley's parents go?
Brian，Harley 的父母去哪儿了？
I had them right in that chair, right here all three of them.
我刚才让他们坐在那把椅子上，就在这里，他们三个人。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声音]
He finds they've left.
他发现他们离开了。
On screen, you see a confused Martin looking around anxiously. He's still not done with her, still picturing her in his cast list, but she was gone. For a moment, he stands there probably thinking exactly what I'm thinking.
屏幕上，你可以看到困惑的 Martin 焦虑地环顾四周。他还没搞定她，还在剧组名单里想象她，但她不见了。有一刻，他站在那里，可能在想和我完全一样的事情。
Why the hell would you ever walk out on that? Harley threw away her shot, and ever since I've wondered why. So I tracked her down. She was really surprised to hear from me. It was so long ago, she said, but she was also totally game to talk. Harley and I actually have a lot in common.
为什么你他妈会放弃那个机会？Harley 丢掉了她的机会，从那以后我一直在想为什么。所以我追踪到了她。她真的对我的联系感到惊讶。那是很久以前的事了，她说，但她也完全乐意谈谈。Harley 和我其实有很多共同点。
We're both from the East Coast, we're both 30 years old, born just 10 days apart. She remembers everything about the audition.
我们都来自东海岸，我们都 30 岁，出生日期仅差 10 天。她记得关于试镜的一切。
And then I remember these, like, boards we had to walk under. It was like you had to be under a certain height to even go into the audition, cause you had to walk under these kids-only things.
然后我记得这些，就像我们必须走过去的板子。就像为了去试镜你必须低于一定身高，因为你必须走过这些小孩专用的东西。
They decided that orphans were a certain height?
他们决定孤儿一定要达到一定身高？
I guess so. I mean, I was certainly getting under that. So I'd probably still get under that today.
我想是这样。我是说，我肯定低于那个。所以我今天可能还是能通过。
By the way, Harley has dwarfism. That's what she meant by that joke. She's 4 foot 6. I pretty quickly got to the point. Why did you walk out that day? And the answer was not what I expected at all. I thought Harley was bombing because of what Barbara Walters said, because she had stage fright. But it wasn't nerves stopping her.
顺便说一句，Harley 有侏儒症。那是她那个笑话的意思。她身高 4 英尺 6 英寸。我很快进入了正题。你那天为什么要走掉？答案完全出乎我的意料。我以为 Harley 是因为 Barbara Walters 说的那样炸掉了，因为她有舞台恐惧症。但不是紧张阻止了她。
That's not stage fright. That's frustration that I can't sing. I'm not scared, I'm pissed. Like, I'm mad at myself in that moment.
那不是舞台恐惧症。那是由于我唱不了歌而产生的挫败感。我不怕，我生气。就像，那一刻我在生我自己的气。
(SINGING) You're always a day--
(演唱) 你永远是一天——
A-
啊——
I have no pitch, and the poor man was trying so hard to get me to sing the right note, and I just couldn't do it. Start to get hot. Your hands start to get clammy, your heart starts to race. All these people are now looking at me. And I don't know what to do.
我完全不在调上，那个可怜的人努力想让我唱对音符，但我就是唱不出来。开始感到热了。你的手开始出汗，你的心开始跳动。所有这些人现在都在看着我。我不知道该做什么。
Which of course casts her sudden disappearance in an entirely different light.
这当然以完全不同的角度展现了她突然的失踪。
It was not a feeling of fear of being on stage, or fear of auditioning. It was just an overwhelming feeling of this not being right for me. Think it was just this isn't what I want to be doing right now. It stopped being fun, and I just looked at both of my parents and I said, I'm done. I don't-- I don't want to do this anymore. I'm ready to go. And there was absolutely no questioning of me on that at all. They said, OK, let's go.
那不是对舞台的恐惧，也不是对试镜的恐惧。那只是一种 overwhelming 的感觉，觉得这不适合我。我想这只是我现在不想做的事情。它不再有趣了，我只是看着我的父母说，我做完了。我不要——我不想再做这个了。我准备走了。对此绝对没有任何疑问。他们说，好的，我们走吧。
Were you embarrassed leaving? Did you say goodbye to people? Like, the way it's framed in the show is this very abrupt thing. But how did it feel in the moment? What did it look like?
你离开时尴尬吗？你和人们道别了吗？节目里的框架是这非常突然的一件事。但在那一刻感觉如何？它看起来像什么？
The moment my parents said we could leave, I was comfortable. I was like all right, guys. Let's get out of here. Let's go get a snack.
我父母说我们可以离开的那一刻，我很舒服。我心想，好吧，伙计们。让我们离开这里吧。去吃点东西。
Why she didn't stick around that day, it wasn't an act of fear. It was an act of courage.
她那天没待在那里，这不是恐惧的行为。这是一种勇气的行为。
I feel like I've always been pretty in tune with myself. And I know when something is not right. And I've done this with other things in my life, where I've gotten pretty far with something, and then I'm like eh, I think we're done.
我觉得我一直很了解自己。我知道什么时候事情不对劲。我生活中也对其他事情做过同样的事，我在这方面走得很远，然后我想，呃，我想我们做完了。
So there's this like other little person inside of you.
所以你心里有另一个小人儿。
Is that a short joke?
那是身高歧视笑话吗？
It wasn't a short joke, but when I said it, I was worried that you might think it is. But it wasn't. So there was, I'm going to start over. So there was a voice in your head speaking to you in a language that you understand, but couldn't quite speak yet.
这不是身高歧视笑话，但当我说了之后，我担心你可能会那么想。但这并不是。所以有，我要重新开始。所以你脑子里有一个声音用一种你理解但还说不出的语言在和你说话。
100%, yes.
100%，是的。
But what you were able to interpret in the moment was?
但你在那一刻能解读的是？
This isn't right for me.
这不适合我。
And I don't feel good.
而且我感觉不好。
Yeah.
是的。
And I need to get out.
而且我需要离开。
I need to leave.
我需要离开。
So at 7, Harley understood enough to know she wasn't good enough. She walked away. She felt fine. Me, it took me much longer to figure it out. I auditioned for the 8th grade musical, and didn't get in.
所以 7 岁时，Harley 理解自己不够好。她走开了。她感觉很好。对我来说，我花了很多时间才弄明白。我试镜了 8 年级的音乐剧，没进。
I auditioned for the 9th grade musical, didn't get in. I auditioned for the 10th grade play, and didn't get in. I tried transferring to Interlochen, an elite arts boarding school for teens. Didn't get in. My senior year of high school, all the kids enrolled in theater were given one song to sing in an end-of-year revue.
我试镜了 9 年级的音乐剧，没进。我试镜了 10 年级的戏剧，没进。我尝试转到 Interlochen，一所为青少年开设的精英艺术寄宿学校。没进。高四那年，所有选修戏剧的孩子都在年终回顾演出中获得了一首歌唱的机会。
The teacher gave me an easy one, a song from the musical "Hairspray." About growing up.
老师给了我一首容易的，来自音乐剧《发胶星梦》的歌。关于长大的。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) Once upon a time, I used to play with Kens. But now that I'm a woman, I like bigger men.
(演唱) 曾经，我用来玩肯尼娃娃。但现在我是一个女人了，我喜欢更大的男人。
When the song shifted into the high notes, I talked the lyrics instead of singing them, hoping it'd make it look intentional, like a character choice.
当歌曲进入高音时，我用说话代替了唱歌，希望这看起来是故意的，像一种角色选择。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
(演唱) [听不清]
Harley's a bad singer, but she's obviously got something. She's a good actor. What you don't find out about her in that Barbara Walters special is that she actually went onto a pretty successful child acting career. She starred in a Nick at Nite short, multiple commercials, even a Val Kilmer movie. But me?
Harley 是个糟糕的歌手，但她显然有某种东西。她是个好演员。你在那个 Barbara Walters 特辑中没发现的是，她实际上继续了相当成功的童星职业生涯。她出演了一部 Nick at Nite 短片，多部商业广告，甚至一部 Val Kilmer 的电影。但我呢？
So OK, Mama. Be honest, OK?
所以 OK，妈。老实点，好吗？
I called my mom in Greece to ask.
我给在希腊的妈妈打电话问。
Was I talented?
我有天赋吗？
You were-- you had talent. But you know, I don't believe you were the star, the big star. You never got the leading role.
你——你有天赋。但你知道，我不相信你是明星，那个大明星。你从来没得到过主角。
Actually, I, like, often didn't even get in at all. And so I don't really understand why I held on to that dream for too long.
实际上，我经常甚至根本进不去。所以我真的不明白为什么我太久地抓着那个梦想不放。
You loved it, Lina. You loved it. I mean, you loved the musicals. I mean, you were like an encyclopedia. I have a very vivid memory of you going to Borders on your tippy-toes, asking the person behind the desk for the musical "Annie Get Your Gun." And you were telling him you want the 1938. No, it wasn't '38, because in '39 Judy Garland did "Wizard Of Oz."
你爱它，Lina。你爱它。我是说，你爱音乐剧。我是说，你就像一本百科全书。我有一个非常深刻的记忆，是你踮着脚尖走到 Borders，向柜台后面的人询问音乐剧《飞燕金枪》。你告诉他你要 1938 年的。不，那不是 38 年，因为 39 年 Judy Garland 演了《绿野仙踪》。
OK. So I had different talents. Harley says that when acting stopped being fun, she moved on. She's a teacher now in New Jersey. And of course, I've moved on, too. Mostly. Almost entirely. Really, any day now.
好吧。所以我确实有不同的天赋。Harley 说当演戏不再有趣时，她就继续前进了。她现在是新泽西州的一名教师。当然，我也继续前进了。大多数时候。几乎完全。真的，任何时候都可以。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Lina Misitzis is one of the stars of our show.
Lina Misitzis 是我们节目的明星之一。
[MUSIC - PRINCE, "I'M A STAR"]
[音乐 - PRINCE, "I'M A STAR"]
The program is produced by Diane Wu. The people put the show together includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chase, Dana Chivvis Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graves, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Raymond, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum.
该项目由 Diane Wu 制作。将节目放在一起的人包括 Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Ben Calhoun、Zoe Chase、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Aviva DeKornfeld、Damien Graves、Seth Lind、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Raimondo、Ben Phelan、Nadia Raymond、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney 和 Nancy Updike。我们的总编辑是 David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to Michael Margolis, Greg Collelo, Henry Molofsky, Courtney Harold, Joel Lovell, Diane Hodson, Nielsen Global Media and Lisa Morel. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. Look at our app, and you can download as many of them as you want. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢 Michael Margolis、Greg Collelo、Henry Molofsky、Courtney Harold、Joel Lovell、Diane Hodson、尼尔森全球媒体和 Lisa Morel。我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org，您可以在那里免费流媒体播放我们超过 600 集的存档。看看我们的应用程序，您可以根据需要下载尽可能多的内容。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks as always for the program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and I went to the beach last weekend. I did not realize he had never been to the beach. He was shocked. He could not stop saying.
一如既往地感谢节目的联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生。你知道吗，上周末我们去了海滩。我没意识到他从来没去过海滩。他惊呆了。他无法停止说。
Oh, no, looks like we've got another shirtless dude.
噢，不，看起来我们又有另一个打赤膊的家伙了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories on This American Life.
我是 Ira Glass。下周回到《美国生活》讲述更多故事。
[MUSIC - PRINCE, "I'M A STAR"]
[音乐 - PRINCE, "I'M A STAR"]